I only have to think about movement and
I can start and stop like stop now these
small steps open a new chapter in
medical technology
gertyan was paralyzed in a cycling
accident 12 years ago he was told he
would never walk again
[Music]
but for the first time doctors Abridged
the damaged spinal cord with wireless
digital implants that turn his thoughts
into action with life-changing results
I promised my father to walk again now
yeah I don't know if I promised it but I
told him I will walk again and with his
last birthday I
I went
with the Walker to the birthday party so
um it was a big surprise for my father
to see me without a wheelchair
the device has two parts in the brain
implants are placed over the Region's
controlling movement then in a backpack
a computer powered with artificial
intelligence decodes brain signals
generated when Gert yarn thinks about a
particular movement and sends an
instruction wirelessly to a second
device implanted in his lower back
Bridging the damage to the spinal cord
in his neck it sends electrical impulses
through the nerves to coordinate the leg
muscles and allow him to walk yeah we
believe this is a real breakthrough here
it's not controlling robots it's really
reconnecting to regions of the central
nerve system that are disconnected this
is like the true digital revolution in
terms of Prosthetics you know it's a
completely new Dogma that is starting
with the of course a proof of principle
only one patient but it shows us that
it's not science fiction anymore and
that's a new era for these people that
New Hope can be given to people with a
spinal cord injury
the Swiss team is preparing to roll out
the technology to other patients with
spinal injuries and perhaps then those
Paralyzed by stroke but one UK charity
warned against raising false hope these
breakthroughs are really exciting but
also tempered with
um how few people this has been used in
so far and how far down the line it
might take to to actually be be useful
to for the whole population of which
there are thousands of us in the UK at
the moment that need support in a whole
variety of ways
but take nothing away from the
technology the thoughts of a paralyzed
man his intent to walk can now be turned
into deliberate steps
foreign